des pierres et des barres de fer pour
exprimer leurs colères pour la deuxième
journée de suite les partisans de
l'ancien Premier ministre pakistanais
Imran Khan sont descendus dans la rue un
peu partout au pays pour dénoncer son
arrestation
[Applaudissements]
nous ne ferons aucun compromis
jusqu'à ce qu'il soit libérés ajoute
cette dame
les émeutes meurtrières ont débuté dans
l'état du pendja
avant de s'étendre rapidement ailleurs
dans le pays
les blessés se comptent par centaines
dont beaucoup de policiers selon le
gouvernement qui a dépêché des soldats
sur place pour établir l'ordre les
arrestations se multiplient déjà un
millier en moins de 48 heures partout à
travers le pays les écoles ont été
fermées les autorités ont aussi
restreint l'accès aux réseaux
cellulaires et aux médias sociaux comme
Twitter et Facebook mais les violences
risquent fort de se poursuivre alors
qu'un tribunal spécial vient d'ordonner
la détention provisoire des bras de
Cannes pour une période de huit jours
s'il multiplie les appels au calme les
alliés et les proches de l'ancien
Premier ministre appelé ses partisans a
continué de se faire entendre
c'est maintenant plus que jamais le
moment pour le peuple de se soulever
contre cette loi martiale de son avocat
il a même accusé récemment la
hiérarchies militaire d'avoir tenté de
le faire assassiner mais les autorités
sont formelles elles ne font qu'à piquer
la loi des réseaux
politique affirme ce ministre l'unité
anticorruption est indépendante et le
mandat d'arrêt et légal
dans ce bras de fer qui l'oppose à
l'armée toute puissante dans le pays
Imran Kane joue gros et le Pakistan en
paix le prix la stabilité a fait
s'effondrer le cours de la monnaie
nationale et l'inflation des records à
46%. par semaine ici Jean-François
Bélanger Radio-Canada Montréal